hey guys if you're looking for good
sound biblical teachings in truth in
love and through the spirit that's not
preaching to itchy ears just what
people's fleshly Natures want to hear
but sound biblical Doctrine then join DM
men's lifestyle this is the Men's
Ministry you're looking for and this is
some of what you can expect to see and
hear if you're lost if you're trying to
make sense of the world trying to make
sense of your purpose why you are here
what is your
meaning then you need to understand that
you can only find the answers in truth
itself and God himself who created You
In His Image you are not just some
random
mistake you are created in God's image
for a purpose and he's waiting for you
to near him with all your heart trying
to get rich quick often leads to
financial ruin because you're doing that
you're walking in your own will your own
desires fleshly desires you're not
walking in God's will we need to work
hard for the money that we receive you
need to earn it many of you still look
back on your failures and you're letting
it Define who you are there was
definitely a flood and we don't just
read that from the Bible but from other
civilizations not just two or three but
almost from all of them it says that we
have to Be watchful our are you are you
always on guard looking out because we
are in a battle whether you like it or
not and you need to Be watchful you need
to be careful you need to be on guard
being able to see when evil is attacking
you or your family you also need to be
able to discern to watch out there in
the world to see what darkness is doing
we will all die someday you might even
die soon and then where will you go when
you
die
this life is not all there
is and I want you to be with me in
eternal
life man I would be so special if I can
talk to some of you guys we might never
meet in this life but in the life after
this one for sure God was saying to me
choose me or choose your dad and you
need to understand my dad was everything
for me he was my role
model excuse excuse me my pillar it
wasn't
easy God was saying choose me am I
everything to
you or do you choose your dad it was the
same thing he asked Abraham to sacrifice
his son
Isaac the test to put him
first that is the day I fully
surrendered to Christ I went to China
and that is where God told me to become
a preacher
to share his gospel to the ends of the
world you see David did not fight
through the flesh with his own power he
fought with God's power that was in him
through the spirit you see he did not
have selfconfidence he had God
confidence you know I've been called
vain as well when I was younger and
here's the truth I
was I was vain until God opened my
spiritual eyes and I saw myself for what
I
was at that time a wretched arrogant
human being I felt like the worst person
ever when God showed me my pride put God
first in your marriage in everything
that you do it is God's word that says
that you have to love your wife not when
you feel like it it's a command it's an
act of your will not just a feeling the
feeling a lot of people focus on that
kind of love is the OS love sexual love
the attraction love there's also agape
love which is the unconditional love
that God has for us that's the love that
you also have to have for your wife to
love her even when you don't feel like
it when we become reborn Christians we
receive a new spiritual nature the Holy
Spirit right so we have that nature we
also still have that old sinful flesh
and when we act through the spirit we
will not sin this new nature helps us to
overcome sin but when we don't act
through the spirit when we act through
the flesh we will sin we will fall and
so not only do we receive the new
spiritual nature we also become children
of God he adopts us after he declared us
as righteous but that doesn't mean that
when we sin he will just think okay
that's fine and just leave it he
disciplines us as a good father because
he loves us you can trust God with
everything in you but you cannot always
trust people people H you need need to
be very careful in who you trust but you
can't trust God because he knows what's
going on in your life anyway he knows
everything so you need to be vulnerable
to him especially but you don't need to
be vulnerable to all people evil is
taking over is certain areas causing
suffering that's
unnecessary because we are supposed to
be the light in the world to help the
poor to help the weak but a lot of
Christian men are doing nothing you are
called to be the light of the world and
to go and make disciples of all people
do you get it this world can do what it
wants to you but if your confidence is
in God you will always have peace and
joy it's like the tree you know the rain
can come the storms can come the sun can
beat in the day but the roots are in the
Living Water join us by subscribing to
our Channel where you can expect to see
weekly videos that you can watch that
you can share and that you can comment
on with the rest of the DM family this
world and the things of this world it's
all passing away we're in this world but
we're not part of this world so join us
by putting Christ first and always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours bye